mon chéri ouais ça va ça va très bien et
est très beau comme ça le dimanche 8 mai
très en forme aux métiers d'art 10 rue
refaire la photo de classe en faisant
baisser rideau les dangers la fière
d'être dans ta tête tout mignon b12 b2
de bd est alors bouffon bref les chéris
c'est récent mathieu fond tu vas aller
chercher une personne dans public cette
personne doit pouvoir emporter 500 euros
puisque 500 euros pour la personne et
500 euros pour quelqu'un sur twitter
hier
hier c'est eric naulleau qui a été notre
champion d'hier et comme tu es son
préféré il a voulu tu le représente
il peut pas d'airé puisqu'il m'a dit que
l'as cannes a souhaité que la cagnotte
augmente encore white a choisi parce
qu'il est persuadé que ne va pas
répondre à la question que je vais te
poser dans un an
attention mathieu va chercher quelqu'un
dans public qui va pouvoir gagner 500
euros à des bâtiments c'est quoi une
jolie fille dépêche-toi les repères et
une alerte toute timide
est ce que tu veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont des synchroniser sur les sites
de catastrophes le vrai qu'on sait pas
pourquoi une minutie c'est parce qu'ils
lui pointe par la tête c'est sûr allez
je vais maintenant bayou odra comment tu
t'appelles match la joie
moi j'en adjoint jean matheu faire un
bisou oui bonjour merci d'être là tu as
un amour je fais quoi dans la vie
chez l'étudiante c'était magnifique
entre merci j'ai d'ailleurs c'est vrai
c'était contente de voir matthieu
delormeau
ouais tu aimes bien c'est vrai non moi
je les aime bien ça a été préféré à
l'émission c'est vrai la porte en moi tu
vois et votre mobile et nous on n'aime
pas ouais c'est ça il faut sa place chez
rim on lève on n'aime pas c'est ce qu'on
dit souvent non mais c'est vrai qu'on
aime ou qu'on n'aime pas des thèmes plus
ceux qui n'aiment pas non non je les
aime bien ça marche pas la gueule mais
je voulais aussi reconnaît quelqu'un qui
dit la vérité
eh ben je vais retrouver tout merci
[Rires]
ma joie sincère c'est qui ton préféré ça
se finit pas du tout les aime tous non
vraiment tous après c'est sûr j'ai
quelques préférences
j'ambitionne mère castaldi mathieu
laurent moi c'est fait c'est fou ça les
trois plus un gars allez ma chérie on va
jouer pour 500 euros pour toi et 500
euros pour une personne qui est
tranquillement chez elle et je vais
poser une question battu de longs mois
il aura 15 secondes pour m et dieu sait
que matthieu delormeau il peut en faire
des choses en cas ceux inscrits beurre
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui se filment en
direct en train de jouer aux jeux vidéo
tu savais ce que c'était
évidemment c'est pour les enfants
précisé vient de battre un record
d'heures de jeu en direct vrai tu as 15
secondes pour me dire combien d'heures
at il joué en un mois si tu trouve
exactement le nombre d'heures je te
dirai plus ou moins à chaque fois tu
fera gagner 500 euros en ajoie et 500
euros à une personne sur twitter tu
perds il y aura 500 euros de plus demain
dans la cagnotte attend agences de lui
l'homme aux quinze secondes 320 plus en
plus 600 mois 550 +170 plus 580 mois 575
mois temps sont 18 à 74 73 72
[Applaudissements]
la formation
allez vas t'asseoir mathieu bravo très
gros bravo najwa tu gagnes ça ce héros
et il ya une personne sur twitter qui
gagne également 500 euros grâce à
matthieu delormeau
c'est bien la première fois qu'il va
faire gagner de l'argent à des chances